tout le monde voulait qu'on sorte du
gouvernement mais comme c'est cécile il
a annoncé la première on lui fait payer
le fait qu'elle ait eu raison avant les
autres qui lui ont fait payer que europe
écologie c'était elle et c'est la
catastrophe politique donc qui l'ont
éjecté éliminé dès le premier tour la
favorite exprimé sa déception sur
facebook par la défaite à mohéli très
difficile parce qu'effectivement elle
six voiliers au niveau de la
présidentielle était la manière de loin
oui bien sûr c'est d'ailleurs je pense
aussi cela qu'est paye et le côté aux
coupeurs de têtes des dévers qui
continuent un peu une forme suicide
collectif
jean vincent placé à chaque fois qu'il
fait une déclaration se demande qu'elle
pourrait peut être l'argument juste
avant qu'il fasse sa déclaration
tu aurais pu faire qu'ils disent
exactement le contraire par lé parti en
disant en ne pensant pas aux
conséquences que ça aurait pour
l'écologie résultat elle a abîmé
l'écologie et sa stratégie belle s'est
retourné contre elle par une morale le
cynisme en politique de madame duflot
quête ministre qu'après à cracher dans
la soupe
le kiné mais que par son intérêt
personnel a été balayée par les
militants écologistes qui j'ai entendu
hier le ministre de l'intérieur on va ce
qui nous sert de ministre de l'intérieur
qu'à osé dire honte sur lui qu après
quatre ans et demi au pouvoir c'est moi
qui était responsable et manifestations
de policiers
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire aux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
nicolas sarkozy que la manière dont il
s'est exprimé sur les ondes ce matin
ne correspond pas à ce que ce qu'est ma
conception de la politique
rémois la façon dont elle est ministre
de l'intérieur ne correspond pas à
l'idée que je me fais d'un ministre de
l'intérieur qui devrait devancer hommes
et qui devrait aller défendre 157
déplacement depuis 2013 mais c'est plus
bruno le renouveau cetc forrest gump en
fait
dites moi en plus bas sur le dos vous
permettez monsieur le maire je me
permettrai pas de vous appeler par votre
prénom
non monsieur vous m'appelez madame joie
chez arnaud mais vous ne m'appelez pas
ghislaine je suis pas votre ami
ce troisième et dernier débat
présidentiel constituait l'ultime chance
pour donald trump de combler son retard
sur hillary clinton dans les sondages à
leur arrivée les deux candidats ne se
serre pas la main télévision comment
pouvez vous dire quoi franchi la ligne
jaune au contraire on a un patron de
gauche qui fait de la réinsertion
sociale tout d'un coup au lieu de partir
en prison va travailler à canal+ cette
élection
bon dit mois sur l'autre et simple du
tout là